this morning marks one year since the
deadly collapse of champlain towers
south in surf side florida just north of
miami beach ninety-eight people were
killed when the condo tower gave way in
the middle of the night the collapse is
still under investigation manuel
bojorquez is in surf side where the
community is honoring the victims manuel
good morning
good morning nate at 1 22 a.m the time
the building collapsed the victims
families gathered here at the now empty
site and held a private vigil first lady
jill biden is expected to attend a
ceremony later this morning and while
the day certainly will be filled with
grief a survivor story is also giving
hope
something's going on here you got to get
us out of here okay you're in your
apartment right now yes but half the
building's done
from the pile of crumbled concrete and
steel that minutes earlier was champlain
tower south
only three people emerged alive among
them 16 year old devin gonzalez i
remember falling for a brief second yeah
and then i
just blacked out
good job
miami cbs station wfor has for months
followed devin's physical and emotional
recovery and that of her mother angela
who also was rescued from the rubble
when i see videos of
the collapse it's still shocking for me
because my mind just always goes to how
did we even survive that waking up to
the building's rumbling angela grabbed
devon and believed to have run towards
the unit's front door when the floor
split in half causing them to fall more
than 60 feet onto the debris devon's
father edgar would not survive
i'm pretty sure
he would give me like words of
encouragement but i don't
i don't know
go a little bit faster
devon's injuries included a compound leg
fracture
six
good hope has come in the drive of
returning to the sport she loves
volleyball step by step good hop by hop
from like a like traumatic
perspective it's like i didn't lose
everything it's a bright spot in what
has otherwise been a painful year with
victims families still waiting to find
out exactly what caused the collapse
federal investigators are examining
concrete slabs and columns but say a
full report may not be complete until
2024 and after initially failing to pass
a condo safety law florida lawmakers did
so during a special session last month
the law requires condo associations to
set aside money for repairs and certain
condo buildings to be inspected and
recertified at 30 years old or 25 years
if they are within three miles of the
coast
state senator jason pizza who represents
the area pushed for the law but says the
state must now devote resources and
funding to make it work a lot of my
colleagues are not going to get any
votes out of this
there really is no intrinsic value to
other than being the right thing to do
for life safety
a judge has now finalized a one billion
dollar settlement for families who own
condos here there are still
disagreements about where a permanent
memorial should go and what should
happen to the site but it is set to be
sold to a developer from dubai
gail
all right manuel thank you very much the
video you see it and it's still shocking
all this time to see that building come
down we want to give a special thank you
to our affiliate that's wfor because
they shot a lot of the video you saw in
that piece can't do this job without the
affiliates i know coming from an
affiliate background i get it